like this in front of college feels like
the next album cover to the next special
right here yeah
[Music]
so
oh hey everybody i'm just here cleaning
around the house welcome back we got
season three of tacos contour we're at
tacos contour headquarters and you know
what people sometimes ask me do you get
paid for those episodes on first week
fees i said yeah man how do you think i
afforded this 1.4 million dollar seven
bedroom house with one and a half
bathrooms
through tacos contour
today is my day off and we're gonna do a
little taco tour first we're gonna meet
up with a good friend of mine you
remember him from season one do you
remember the guy that was wearing the
guayabeta that kind of looked like a
bowling shirt that's my dear friend mr
bill esparza the green beret
of l.a taco scene also we have a very
special guest i'm meeting up with the
homie from mexico city as a matter of
fact i opened for him last night in
downtown l.a you know what i'm talking
about that's carlos guayata he's one of
the pioneers of the stand-up scene in
mexico three netflix specials an amazing
dude and a great great
great set of hair first we're gonna go
get some barbacoa a barbara kush and
then we're gonna get a whole hog taco
all right let's get started all right
all right
[Music]
this is great all right
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
what was that oh the sound thing
[Music]
what's up bro what's up bro
dude thanks for being here man thank you
man mr bill esparza what's up hey what's
up man how are you doing all right dude
thanks for being here yes wendell zias
what happened to the bowling shirt man
next season next season okay we're going
to hold you to that it's probably the
dry cleaners right now so when i tell
you the words taco scholar what comes to
mind
it is a figure of big respect if you
guys mean
have you heard that title before yeah
yeah i saw you in the first season yeah
bill my man
the twitter numbers are hidden
yeah
i guess i spend a little bit more time
thinking about it i've been to every
state of mexico so nice and how many
states are in mexico there are 31 states
and there's also that's true
yeah
and and
mexico so you have a fact check around
32 regions 32 regions that's right 32
right here
i watched the first season and i saw a
lot of good tacos like this is good
we're usually very [ __ ] like i don't
think it's gonna be good if you're not
right yeah that's what we do well i'm
i'm glad you said that because i'm gonna
try to challenge that on this taco tour
and uh you gotta help me show them that
we're like neck and neck with the
capital of tacos what are we about to
get into right now today we're going to
puebla right here puebla so we're going
to have some barbacoa poblano and then
we're going to try some tacos
okay the lechon from
from
which is again something you'd never
find in mexico city should we go check
it out let's do it all right let's do it
[Music]
feels like a taco speakeasy right that's
like a sign of a good takariya place
right they got like the the things
hanging by the comments semi truck
hubcap with the handles on the side you
know how you go to like certain
restaurants they got like a crab tank or
like fishes we have turtles here
have you heard of papalo before yeah you
eat that and it just brings up the taste
really good popular where he's from
wow oh there's that mole of the panza
noodle oh my god oh yeah
you want this grass
console oh my goodness
all right thanks man yeah
[Music]
like this no it's my favorite part of
this like the console with chickpeas and
everything it is damn i feel like this
is like my favorite kind of uh incense
right here to get rid of bad spirits
yeah i mean this is the sign of a good
one like you know
okay
everywhere this is good it's like an oil
check in the car check the oil yeah yeah
check the level on it just dip it there
and it's like wow this is gonna be good
check it out
wow
here let's turn this this way
oh okay yeah put that in front of carlos
this feels like this in front of college
feels like the next album cover to the
next special right here yeah hey
this is barbacoa
we have lamb of course
lamb skulls
con garbanzo mole de panza enchilada are
lam menudo and what's really wonderful
about this is that some of the cuts the
the stomach cuts she smokes in the pit
along with the barbacoa barbacoa oh wow
this is like a mixtape yeah this is
tacos contolo this is tacos yeah there's
nothing more after this
my
is anderson rodriguez
my
name
felix rodriguez nosotros la familia
barbacus
barbacoa poblano barbacoa aqui los
angeles
a
we don't add no ingredients to it
because everything is just agave
[Music]
is
is great mirror mirror on the wall who's
the most
uh cholesterol filled artery you can get
it
these aren't flying this season huh
that was funny on paper bill i tell you
it's like i don't even want to talk man
stand up as we know it has been around
in the states for 40 plus years now
stand up in mexico city i think is
roughly and correct me if i'm wrong
carlos roughly 10 years yeah could be 10
years how does one start a stand-up
scene in a place that they don't have a
palette for it it was tough at the
beginning some people were like they
didn't really want to do it they didn't
want to
listen to it yeah but you just do it and
you try to perfect it as much as you can
and then you create kind of like a brand
and people react to brands rather than
the craft itself so that was good that's
the way that i found to translate that
was this always carlos i've always loved
long hair
ever since i was like
yeah and then life is very cruel man
i love long hair it just wasn't for me i
guess the very first year i was doing
stand-up i was not looking at the
audience in the eyes because i was so
scared and i was just like [ __ ]
looking up or looking down and my hair
was covering my face so people weren't
really connecting and i knew i had to do
something a huge kurt cobain fan right
and i found glasses that looked like
similar to what he
wore
so i remember that i just i took them
went on stage felt a lot more
comfortable and that kind of like stuck
so now that you've been touring the us a
lot more yeah is there anything that
like any observations that stick out to
you is like oh that's funny that would
that doesn't happen in mexico or it's
like that's just weird
yeah man whenever you're on stage i i've
noticed that audiences here in the us
they like to say some stuff
when you're on stage you know like a
heckler not much like heckler it is a
heckler but people are just saying yeah
that's what happens that's right they
like to comment on your jokes that
doesn't happen in mexico you're like i
got all right guys you got you have to
be quiet while i'm doing this and people
are laughing they're like wow yeah
that's right and that's funny man they
they they want to talk to you in a way
yeah
bill wait a grab
a piece of meat
uh pause
you know what bums me out you guys what
man this is what bums me on how did this
[ __ ] got better teeth than me
i mean
he went through a fire pit and his teeth
are way straighter than mine
i think it's really
authentic yeah tastes really good you
got handmade tortillas which is
something really cool
you got the actual head right here
cilantro
that's like i don't know how they cut
this here but this is great this is
great i think it's uh
five out of five i hope you guys aren't
too full because we still got another
spot
i can tell you like one of my favorite
jokes that ronnie dangerfield just in
the misdirect one-liner kind of realm
yeah like he had this joke where it was
like uh i went to my dentist the other
day i said doctor you got to help me my
my teeth are yellow what do you think i
should do he's a what about a brown
bowtie
i mean talk about a mystery yeah i mean
genius is [ __ ] great who are some of
your favorites
uh mitch hedberg uh stephen wright
that's mostly i love stephen wright yeah
i love steven wright great man stephen i
had one of my favorite jokes he's like
uh he's like i'm writing a book about a
photographer that went crazy trying to
uh a photograph of the horizon up close
close up the horizon yeah
he had this one joke i [ __ ] love him
like he said i went to a i went to a
drive-in in
a cab the movie cost me 95
he's so cool man
[Music]
i know you haven't had this before no
both of you this is new to you
but this is taco
but specifically from
so they got a special little thing that
they do this mustard salsa
so it's right up my alley good how are
you
jesus nice to meet you chris chris
[Applause]
and look at that whoa
right there yeah all right
see you take a look there you guys have
that wow man some new something why is
it six pack on its back
that's a 24 pack that's 24 packs
and so they call this porquito echado
where they're from so flattened
flat
yeah
[Music]
wow
[Music]
i'm christian david we are with los
angeles
that's right whole oven roasted pig we
make whole suckling pig tacos it's
something different unique that comes
from where my dad is from agape
and we're basically the only ones in all
la who do this personally i go for a
mixture of the crunchy and the tender
stuff from the neck area up the meat is
super super tender apart from your
salsas you have your limes and cabbage
they call it master salsa which gives it
a any flavor there's no other salt so
that's going to go with that type of
taco and of course
always got to have a side of pork skin i
was just in my back in my town like last
week and and and they said well david i
mean
you know we're glad that you're doing
this in out of the country you know and
far from our
from our land and and that makes you
feel
i mean grateful really good
so you've never seen anything like this
in mexico city it's not a thing right
that's not a thing yes it's funny about
los angeles because we we're at these uh
pueblo with the the the barbacoa pueblo
style right and then we got this night
in mexico geographically that's far away
from each other right and then there's
the oaxacan restaurant right there
right there there you go this is los
angeles yeah like we're the avengers of
tacos man all the heroes so what are the
tattoos on the pig what does they stand
for i guess the the quality belongs
yeah so they tattoo the weight of the
pig imagine if they did that with people
it's like oh 280
285 pounds
you see a lot of long sleeve shirts a
lot of long sleeve shirts yeah the
flannel but you got people that come
here and ask for special cuts too yeah
we take special requests like the the
cola yeah like the cola
yeah someone the ears you know yeah
david is actually a fan of yours
yes sir
i'm a big fan of what you do too
i think that it's mutual the respect
right there that's how it goes right
guys yeah
la colitas
enjoy guys thank you take a seat guys
enjoy it
yeah they know me in the streets man
yeah they do so do you eat ass bill
uh well
yeah so that's only when it's crispy and
golden yay
all right
i can't wait yeah uh
porquito echado
all right man
[Music]
wow
to me this is like the perfect
[ __ ] taco because you got the meat
itself is not complete without the salsa
you know
in comedy at least right you have your
one-liner comic you have your
storytelling comic so when it comes to a
taquero what are the three archetypes
yeah there's a lot of showmanship in
mexico city but there's this like it's a
part of the family too because every
every neighborhood has like maybe five
six taquerias and you got your takaria
your favorite one and you go there and
the taquero already knows what you're
gonna order so he's like lo de siempre
and he knows exactly what you like and
he's gonna do it for you the way you
like it that's that's better than
knowing is like the the bar where
everyone knows your name it's like that
kind of that knows your order that's
hidden describe to me your taquero the
one that knows your order uh i remember
when i was a kid i used to go to this
they sold carnitas i remember him
we used to call him el pequeno and i
remember his face because it's a very
intimate relationship
it translates to the little one the
little one yeah and what did he look
like was he was he a short guy or not he
was tall he was a tall guy and he had
like short hair and he was smiling and i
remember his face was so shiny because
of all the other all the fat on his face
i remember this guy's like a saint you
know he was just shiny carnitas stands
in mexico city they got a bulb here and
this guy is shining all through the
night it's his night he's at the start
of the night
he's telling jokes
i remember he's in the spotlight the
whole time yeah i mean i think that's an
archetype too you a lot of taqueros are
comedians yeah they entertain you they
all they just talk [ __ ] on everybody all
day long sometimes there's two taqueros
there's this one guy ordering this guy
and like
people are laughing while they're eating
what does a heckler look like for uh
do you think they have them
maybe they do man i don't know
are you like a believer in the la taco i
am bro yeah you're good yeah go tell the
child
tell everybody bring the good news back
to mexico city they get it because they
don't know over there take our message
out to let them know la we got it we got
hey carlos thank you again really
appreciate you man keep killing it i'm a
big fan and thank you for always being
so welcoming and thank you bill thank
you for always being so chill
super cool thank you for putting up with
my bad jokes
you laughed at that went down
thank you again man appreciate it this
was a pleasure this was awesome
time nice to meet you man
thank you so much for watching this is
tacos contour season three three pete
we'll see you next time
my enemy cholesterol
got cholesterol diabetes cholesterol
diabetes
high blood pressure
oh we're not good
if we were going to jump somebody we
missed every shot just yeah we're not
good it hurts man
[Music]
hello my name is jesus draco i'm the
host of tacos contolo and don't forget
to like and subscribe
you can watch more right here hurry
watch another episode before your boss
comes in and you get fired for real this
time